we discussed sustainable growth on the
basis of a presidency report and the
main message of the report is that
wisely chosen policy measures combined
from different relevant policy areas are
more efficient together than as separate
measures according to the presidency
report which was widely applauded the EU
needs a new comprehensive ambitious and
forward-looking
growth agenda to improve its
productivity and competitiveness on the
global markets at the same time it has
to be made sure that the economic growth
is sustainable both environmentally and
socially it's also become evident that
you should take a stronger role globally
and not be limited to a mere merely
reactive well it is clear that financial
markets play a key role in making
sustainable growth and a transition
towards climate neutrality really
happened to achieve its climate energy
objectives the EU will need considerably
private investments if you want drought
growth that is sustainable economically
environmentally and socially
we need a mixture of different European
policies it will require building
synergies across many policy areas like
industry single market innovation
climate neutral transition of course
digital economy and skills development